- Rewrite Y is equal to
2/3x plus 4/7 in standard form.
The equation must be simplified,
which means all numbers must be integers
that do not share a common
factor other than one.
Alright, we'll worry about this
second part in a little bit.
Let's see if we can rewrite this.
So it's Y is equal to 2/3x plus 4/7.
Let me get my scratch pad out.
So it's Y is equal to
2/3x plus 4/7.
So the way that it's written right now,
this is slope intercept form.
It's written in the form
Y is equal to mx plus b,
where m in this case is 2/3 and b is 4/7.
It's very easy to figure
out what the slope
and what the Y intercept
is from this equation.
But we wanna write this in standard form.
Which would be the form
Ax plus By
is equal to C.
And that extra text they were saying,
the equation must be simplified.
Which means all numbers must be integers
that do not share a common
factor other than one.
That just means that A, B,
and C in the standard form
they want need to be integers.
And they want them to not
have any common factors.
So if we got to the point of say
4x plus 2y
is equal to 10,
well this number, and this
number, and this number
are all divisible by two.
They all have the common factor of two.
So we would want to simplify it more.
Divide them all by two
and then you would get
two so you divide this by two.
You get 2x, divide this by two
you'll get plus y is equal to 5.
So this is the form
that they're asking for
and probably because it's just easier
for the site to know that
this is the right answer.
Because there's obviously a
bunch of forms in this way.
So let's see if we can do that.
Let's see if we can write
it in standard form.
So the first thing I would wanna do is,
well there's a bunch of ways
that you could approach it.
The first thing you could try to do is
well let's get rid of
all of these fractions.
And the best way to get
rid of the fractions
is to multiple by three
and to multiply by seven.
If you multiply by three you
get rid of this fraction.
If you multiply by seven you
So if you multiply three
and you multiply by seven.
Let me just rewrite it over here.
There's actually also a couple
of ways that we can do this.
So if you multiply.
So one way to do it.
So we start with Y is equal to
2/3x plus 4/7.
So if I multiply this side by
three and I multiply by seven,
I have to do that to this side as well.
So this is going to be multiplied by three
and multiplied by seven.
So the left hand side becomes 21y.
21y.
Three times seven of course is
21, we just figured that out.
We would distribute the 21.
21 times 2/3, well let's see.
21 divided by three is
seven, times two is 14.
So it's gonna be 14x.
And then 21 divided by seven
is three times four is 12.
So just like that I was able
to get rid of the fractions.
And now I wanna get all the
X's and Y's on one side.
So I wanna get this
14x onto the left side.
So let's see if I can do that.
So I'm gonna do that by.
To get rid of this I would
want to subtract 14x.
I can't just do it on the right hand side
I have to do it on the
left hand side as well.
So I wanna subtract 14x, and
then what am I left with?
Let me give myself a
little bit more space.
So on the left hand side I have
negative 14x plus 21y.
Plus 21y
is equal to.
Let's see and I subtracted
14x to get rid of this.
And then I have this is equal to 12.
Now let's see, am I done?
Do these share any, do 14, 21, and 12
share any common factors?
Let's see, 14 is divisible
by two and seven.
21 is divisible by three and seven.
12 is divisible by two, six, three, four.
But all of these aren't
divisible by the same number.
14, let's see.
14 is divisible two,
so is 12, but 21 isn't.
14 is divisible by seven,
so is 21, but 12 isn't.
And 21 and 12 are divisible
by three but 14 isn't.
So I think this is about as
simplified as I could get.
If there was a common factor
for all three of these numbers
then I would divide all
of them the way I did
in that previous example.
But that's not the case right over here.
So it's negative 14x
plus 21y is equal to 12.
So let me see if I can
remember that and type that in.
So it is,
negative 14x plus 21y
is equal to 12.
Now let's see if I got it right.
It worked out.